[Music]
people have always migrated the history
of the world is a history of migration
but has migration gone too far
over the past few decades the reasons
for migration have multiplied wars
famines and climate change
pushing people from their homes there's
now the highest number of this place
people worldwide some 66 million people
have been forced elsewhere in the world
of these 23 million refugees the war in
Syria has affected millions of people
some 3.3 million Syrian refugees
currently live in town others fled to
Europe combined with this there's also
economic migration with legal and
illegal since the mid-2000s as the
European Union expanded several million
people have migrated from Eastern Europe
to Britain and other EU countries each
year thousands of migrants from
sub-saharan Africa get on both of the
coast of Libya to try and find working
with this sense of unprecedented scale
has caused a backlash
anti-immigrant sentiments on the rise
Donald Trump capitalized on this when he
talked about building a wall between
America and Mexico open border it's a
it's a sieve we have no idea who's
coming in Germany the right-wing
alternative the Deutsche line has become
the biggest opposition party in
Parliament
this may lead some to included stricter
controls on migration in need there is a
liberal case for open migration
migration often makes a country rich
migrants from the EU are more likely to
be paying taxes than taking our benefits
which governments have a moral case for
helping the most vulnerable in society
with rich world countries shrinking
demographically they will also reap the
benefits down the line but there are
things we can do to help
smarter social integration efforts to
make immigrants stakeholders in society
not just long-term visitors
there is no quick and easy solution to
migration but without making a liberal
case for it
this will divide societies for decades
you